president Trump intends to keep the
terrorist detention facility at
Guantanamo Bay Cuba opened for business
Gitmo former President Obama spent eight
years trying and failing to close it
down national security correspondent
Jennifer Griffin tells us from the
Pentagon
that means suspects could be sent to
Gitmo for the first time in ten years
we're gonna load it up with some bad
dudes believe me we're gonna load it up
candidate Donald Trump promised to
reverse President Obama's decision to
close Guantanamo Bay which the last
administration said terrorists use as a
recruiting tool it was among President
Obama's first executive orders Congress
blocked efforts to close the facility
last night President Trump signed a new
executive order giving defense secretary
mattis who quietly visited the facility
before Christmas 90 days to recommend
whether those captured on the
battlefield should be sent to Gitmo for
the first time in ten years terrorists
are not merely criminals they are
unlawful enemy combatants and when
captured overseas they should be treated
like the terrorists they are Senator
Lindsey Graham has been a loud proponent
of keeping Gitmo open I thought the
president showed a determination as
commander in chief to win a war that we
can't afford to lose that's going to be
used by every
terrorist group worldwide against us
guarded by 1500 US troops 41 prisoners
remain at Guantanamo Bay
among them alleged 9/11 planner Khalid
Sheikh Mohammed 730 detainees have been
transferred to 59 countries since 2002
122 former detainees returned to the
battlefield in the past we have
foolishly released hundreds and hundreds
of dangerous territories only to meet
them again on the battlefield including
the Isis leader al Baghdadi former State
Department officials who worked
tirelessly to close Gitmo say terrorists
are more likely to be convicted in a
federal court the shoe bomber the
underwear bomber the Boston Marathon
bombers all tried in federal court all
convicted all housed in the Federal
Bureau of Prisons not a single security
incident because the US taxpayer about
four hundred and fifty million dollars a
year to keep Gitmo open in 16 years
despite seven active prosecutions there
have been no convictions by these
military tribunals brett jennifer
griffin live at the pentagon Jennifer
thanks